pensemos un poco en cómo se define la
suma de matrices y los matemáticos
tomaron una de las tantas formas para
definir esta suma la cual tiene un gran
sentido el cómo está definida y además
de que tiene propiedades interesantes
que iremos comentando poco a poco así
que si tú fueras uno de estos
matemáticos que tiene la tarea de
definir la suma de matrices como lo
harías
cómo definirías la suma de matrices la
forma de sumar matrices que más
comúnmente se me ocurre es en un
principio fijarnos que estas matrices
tengan la misma dimensión así que fíjate
en esta matriz de una dimensión de dos
por tres dos filas por tres columnas y
esta otra matriz también tiene esta
dimensión dos filas por tres columnas
por lo tanto la suma de matrices se
definió o la definieron los matemáticos
famosos como la suma de la primera
entrada de esta matriz más la primera
entrada de esta segunda matriz y después
vamos a sumar cada entrada de la primera
matriz con su correspondiente entrada de
su segunda matriz para que nos dé un
resultado es decir en este caso es 1
5 lo cual me da 6 y después para darle
nombre a la segunda entrada lo que vamos
a hacer es sumar la segunda entrada de
la primera y de la segunda matriz es
decir menos 70 75 3 es 8 y nos vamos
entrada por entrada
ahora vamos a fijarnos en las entradas
de abajo 0 y 11 me dan de suma 11 3 y
menos 1 me dan de sumar dos positivos
tres menos uno es 2 y después menos 10 7
me dan de suma menos 3 menos 10 más 7
mediante suma menos 3 y quiero que te
des cuenta de dos cosas muy importantes
sumamos cada una de las entradas de esta
primera matriz en cada una de las
segundas entradas correspondientes de la
segunda matriz y lo segundo que quiero
que veas es que la matriz que nos quedó
nos quedó de 2 por 3 también la
dimensión de la matriz resultante tiene
la misma dimensión que las matrices de
la suma ahora bien una de las
propiedades más importantes que quiero
que revisemos es que la suma de matrices
es conmutativa es decir es lo mismo
sumar la primera matriz más la segunda
matriz que la segunda matriz más
matriz y justo esto es lo que vamos a
ver ahorita y por eso estoy copiando y
pegando de nuevo las matrices para que
ustedes se den cuenta que al final es la
suma de números reales porque fíjense
bien como yo definí la matriz esa es una
de las propiedades más bonitas de esta
definición de matrices como yo definir
la suma de matrices lo que hacíamos era
sumar cada una de las entradas la
primera matriz con la cada una de las
entradas de la segunda matriz y aquí
tenemos 5 más 1 lo cual me da 6 y arriba
teníamos 1 + 5 lo cual me daba 6 al
final es la propiedad conmutativa de los
números reales y por lo tanto mi
resultado va a ser el mismo
6 - 7 8 11 2 y menos 3 es decir que si
nosotros tenemos dos matrices una matriz
a más una matriz ven y nos da de
resultado esta de aquí va a ser
exactamente lo mismo aquí si nosotros
sumamos la matriz b más la matriz am y
vamos a obtener entonces el mismo
resultado y bueno esto es muy importante
mencionarlo porque cuando nosotros
hablamos de matrices suele ocurrir esto
en la suma sin embargo una
multiplicación
no pasa lo mismo ahora que ya hemos
visto bastante de la suma la pregunta
sería qué pasa con la resta pasarán
cosas iguales distintas cómo se define
la resta o la diferencia de matrices por
lo tanto aquí estoy poniendo otras dos
matrices y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
la diferencia de matrices y como se
define exactamente igual que la suma a
la primera entrada de la primera matriz
le voy a restar la primera entrada de la
segunda matriz por lo tanto que me va a
quedar de estas dos y es que al final es
lo mismo que si yo pusiera la primera
matriz déjenme copiarla y pegarla aquí
la primera matriz es 0 1 3 y 2 y yo les
sumada al menos 1 es decir multiplicar
por una escalar menos 1 que multiplica a
la segunda matriz y al final es una suma
de matrices una suma de matrices
solamente que la segunda matriz está
multiplicada por el escalar menos 1 por
lo tanto vamos a restar las que me va a
quedar
0 - menos 1 me da 1 positivo uno menos 3
me da menos 2
3 - 0 me da 3 y 2 menos 5 me va a dar
y ya están logré definir o logré
encontrar el resultado de una diferencia
o de una resta de matrices y al final es
lo mismo que tenemos aquí abajo 0 - 1 x
menos uno me da más 1 y me queda 0 + 1
que es 11 + menos 1 por menos 3 nevada
menos 2 etcétera y bueno también es muy
importante que les comenté que tienen
que tener el mismo rango la misma
dimensión las dos matrices y el
resultado también va a tener la misma
dimensión porque por ejemplo si nosotros
tomamos la matriz 1 035 0 1 ya esto le
sumamos la matriz y fíjate que esta
matriz tiene dimensión 3 por 2 yo le voy
a sumar la matriz 57 menos 16 la cual es
una matriz de dos por dos la suma de
estas dos matrices que crees no está
definida
no podemos sumar estas dos matrices
porque entonces nos faltarían renglones
o columnas o lo que sean por lo tanto no
está definida la suma de dos matrices
que no tengan la misma dimensión no
hemos encontrado la forma de que el
resultado de la suma de estas dos
matrices sea
y sea útil para la suma de matrices por
lo tanto si las matrices no tienen la
misma dimensión no está definida la suma